This course consists of four lessons.
Here, in lesson one, we'll go over
the basic of monetization strategies.
And why it's important for you to think
about monetization from the very start.
>> In lesson two, we'll go into detail
on monetization models available for
different types of products.
Feel free to jump around to the content
that is most relevant to your needs.
>> Then, in lesson three,
you'll develop a monetization plan for
the model that you've chosen.
>> And finally, in lesson four,
we'll cover best practices for
measuring the performance of
your monetization strategy.
We'll also talk about when is the right
moment to change your strategy and
optimize it.
>> Our goal in this course is to help
you plan your monetization strategy
in order to have a sustainable business.
>> Sustainable business is
all about making money.
Let's start by talking
about profitability